en los últimos vídeos hemos trabajado
bastante con esta idea de exponentes
negativos tanto que llegamos a la
siguiente relación dijimos que ha
elevado a la menos b
esto lo podemos ver esto es equivalente
a tomarnos a uno a uno ya espera que fue
uno a tomarnos a uno ya este uno
dividirlo entre am entre la misma base
elevado ahora a una potencia positiva y
justo a esta igualdad llegamos y con
ésta hemos venido trabajando bastante en
los vídeos pasados no obstante aunque ya
hemos trabajado mucho con esta idea y
con esta relación me gustaría que
quedara mucho más clara el concepto o la
idea de lo que es un exponente negativo
así que para eso se me ocurre cargamos
un experimento con las potencias de dos
ya ver si así entiendo es un poco mejor
qué es lo que está pasando con un
exponente negativo fíjate bien
imagínate que yo tengo a 2 elevado al
cubo 2 elevado al cubo bueno nosotros
sabemos que esto es lo mismo que 2 x 2 x
2 lo cual es 8 ok y cuánto es 2 elevado
al cuadrado
bueno pues 2 elevado al cuadrado es 2
por 2 lo cual es 4
ok y 2 elevado a la primera potencia
bueno pues esto es 2 esto es 2 date
cuenta que lo que estamos haciendo aquí
es dividiendo entre 2 de aquí y déjame
cambiar de color de aquí para camps lo
que hice fue dividir entre 2 dividir
entre 2 y de aquí para acá lo que hice
fue dividir también entre 2 ok vamos
bastante bien ahora qué te parece si
nosotros pensamos
en 2 elevado a la potencia cero bueno
pues esto va a ser igual y nosotros
siguiendo este mismo patrón
tendremos que dividir el 2 entre 2 2
entre 2 es uno pero además sabemos que
eso es completamente cierto por
definición
^ 0 es 1 y eso lo hemos dicho varias
veces todo número elevado a la 0 es 1
excepto el 0 muy bien pero además lo
podemos ver la siguiente manera si
dividimos el 2 entre 2 llegamos a que 2
elevado a la primera potencia es 2 2
elevado a la potencia 0 es 1 lo único
que estoy haciendo es manteniendo este
patrón de dividir entre 2
ahora vamos un paso más abajo qué te
parece si lo dividimos entre 2 pues
vamos a llegar a que 2 elevado a la
potencia siguiente es decir menos 1 le
voy a bajar 1 el exponente esto va a ser
igual a 1 dividido entre 21 dividido
entre 21
medium que es justo lo que ya sabíamos y
lo podemos ver justo con esta expresión
que tenemos aquí 2 elevado a la menos 1
es 1 / 2 elevado a la primera potencia
pero además acabamos de ver que esto
también es bastante consistente y no
sólo eso date cuenta que todos elevado a
la menos 1 es un medio que es el
recíproco o el inverso multiplicativo de
2 elevado a la primera potencia que por
cierto es 2 pues bueno vamos a
mantenernos haciendo esto para esto
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla vamos a
bajar un poco la pantalla y ahora
trabajemos con las últimas potencias
aunque se me ocurre trabajar con ellas
de dos vamos a hacer a dos elevado a la
menos 2
bueno pues siguiendo este mismo patrón
lo que tengo que hacer es dividir esta
expresión de aquí entre 2 me voy a
dividir otra vez esto entre 2 y aquí voy
a llegar a que esto es exactamente lo
mismo a un medio entre 2 que sabemos que
es un cuarto
un cuarto y otra vez utilizando las
leyes los exponentes tiene bastante
sentido fíjate bien 2 elevado al
cuadrado es 4 y si a esto mismo lo
ponemos 1 entre 4 voy a llegar a 2
elevado a la menos 2 que por cierto es
el inverso multiplicativo de 4 es el
inverso multiplicativo de 4 muy bien y
ya para concluir podemos decir que 2
elevado a la menos 3 es exactamente lo
mismo que un cuarto entre 2 lo cual es
un octavo y lo que estoy haciendo es
dividir este número entre 2 entre 2
siguiendo este mismo patrón y date
cuenta que 2 elevado al menos tres es el
recíproco déjame cambiar de color es el
recíproco de 2 elevado a la tercera
potencia es decir de este de aquí es el
inverso multiplicativo y además 2
elevado a la menos 3 es lo mismo que 1
entre 2 elevado al cubo que es 8 pero ya
está aquí tienes otra manera de pensar
inverso
aplicativos recíprocos pero sobre todo
las potencias negativas tanto viéndolas
como el recíproco de un número o también
las podemos ver como uno entre la misma
base elevada a la misma potencia
solamente que positiva